- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to give an overview
of the types of markets
that you might encounter
in an economics class.
And we're going to get
a little bit precise
with our language 'cause you'll hear words
like perfect competition or monopoly
or oligopoly a lot in economics
and frankly, even in your broader life.
Now before we even go into those terms,
I will differentiate
between what's sometimes
referred to as a product market.
And other markets that are
referred to as resource.
Resource markets.
Now product market is a market
where the output of that market,
what the market is producing
or what it's buying and selling
it is something that people will consume
and it doesn't just have
to be physical product
it could also be some type of a service.
So examples of product markets,
it could be the market for shirts,
it could be cars or it
could even be a service.
It could be tax preparation,
tax preparation.
These would all be product markets
because it's something
that people would consume.
I would call this
consumer tax preparation,
not business tax preparations.
So this is consumer tax preparation.
Now based on my clarification,
you might guess what a
resource market is all about.
These are markets for the
inputs into other products.
Or into the production
of other even resources.
So, these would be your famous
inputs of or factors of production.
It could be, for example,
the market of labor.
It could be something like farm land.
Where farm land is used
to produce something else.
It could be the market for capital goods.
Maybe robots for factories.
But either way, whether we're
talking about product markets
or resource markets, we can
think about them in broad terms
based on how many players
there are in the market
and how differentiated the
players are in the market
and how much control
they have over the price
and how are the barriers to entry.
Let's set up a spectrum here
to explore that a little bit.
So I will set up a spectrum.
Now the extreme end of the
spectrum right over here,
when you only have one player,
one player in the market.
In the market, or actually
let me just say one firm.
Because player's not really
clear on what I'm talking about
whether I'm talking
about a buyer or seller.
One firm in market.
And let's say, many buyers.
Many buyers.
You are probably familiar
with what we call this market
or what we would call this firm.
It has a monopoly!
It has a monopoly name for a famous game
because the whole point of that game
is to try to be that last firm standing.
The firm that owns all of the real estate.
Now what are the situations
that would describe a monopoly?
Well, a monopoly is a situation
where you have very high,
one could argue insurmountable
barriers to entry,
so very high.
High barriers,
barriers to entry.
And monopolies can
sometimes be controversial
but they're not necessarily illegal.
In fact, in many countries, a monopoly
can be granted to a
firm through things like
the intellectual property
or through patents,
for example a drug company
if it discovers a cure
for a drug or something
to maintain a drug,
well they might be granted
a monopoly for that pill
for some period of time and
the government does that
so that they can recoup
their investment in all of
the R&D that they actually produced.
What often is illegal
in a lot of countries,
is if firm misuses its monopoly power.
But anyway, now let's
go to the other extreme.
Let's imagine a situation where instead of
high barriers to entry,
there is no barriers.
No barriers
to entry.
Now let's say that there
is no differentiation.
And you have many players.
So many, or let me write many firms.
I keep wanting to say players,
but that doesn't make it that clear.
And actually let me say
many firms and many buyers.
And many buyers.
Now this is a state that we'll often study
in our economics class, we'll
call it perfect competition.
Perfect
competition.
In a perfect competition world,
the firms are essentially
have to be price takers.
They take whatever the market price is
and we have used that assumption
in a lot of situations.
In a monopoly, on the other side,
they could be the price setters.
They're the only player in that market.
Now, in general when anything
is described as perfect
it's usually theoretical and
so is perfect competition.
There's no markets that I can think of
that are perfectly perfect,
but I can think of ones that are close.
For say, some agricultural commodities.
So say the sugar market.
So the market for sugar might be
pretty close to perfect competition.
There could be many firms, those
would be the farmers, the suppliers.
It would be many buyers
obviously who want sugar.
There would be some barriers to entry.
You'd need to know how to grow sugar,
you would need suitable
land for growing sugar.
But there's a lot of
farmers who might be able
to swap out either sugar cane or beet,
which is where most sugar comes from.
With soy bean or vice versa.
So they can change which crops they plant
and generally speaking, there's
not much differentiation
whether you get sugar
from one farm or another.
So sugar would be pretty
close to perfect competition
and it is the case for a lot
of agricultural commodities
that they do have to be price takers.
There is just a market price
that the individual farmer
is gonna say, oh actually I
wanna charge a little bit more
for that sugar because
they won't be able to.
They're just going to have to take
whatever the price is in the market.
Now as you can imagine,
there is a lot of other
types of markets that are
in between these extremes.
Closer to a monopoly and
similar to a monopoly
in a lot of ways is a
situation where you have
only a handful of firms and
that's referred to oligopoly.
And this is a situation where
you still have high barriers.
So high barriers to entry.
You might have a handful of firms,
so a few firms and you
still have many buyers.
Examples of oligopolies, this could be
things like the aircraft industry.
Air craft.
Where there's huge barriers of entry.
You need to deploy a lot of
capital billions of dollars.
You might have to get government approval
and so that's why,
especially for large aircraft
you only have a few
firms that can produce,
like Boeing or Airbus,
those really large aircraft.
Even in certain cases, automobiles,
sometimes computer manufacturers,
things that have very
high barriers to entry.
If we go a little bit
further to the left, you get
a situation that's known as
monopolistic competition.
Monopolistic, that's
fun to say, competition.
And this you could view
as right in between,
depending on what you're thinking about.
This is a situation where
there's low barriers to entry,
low
low barriers to entry.
There's many firms.
Many firms.
But you do have differentiation.
You do have differentiation
so you can tell
the product of one firm for another.
And I can think of many,
in fact most industries
I can think of fall roughly
in the monopolistic area.
Although we've just mention
some oligopolies and monopolies.
But examples of monopolistic competition,
I can imagine to be things like,
cereal, breakfast cereals
and the breakfast cereal
industry, there is many firms.
There's generally low barriers.
There's some barriers
but they're pretty low
if you want to start a cereal company
a lot of folks might be able to do it.
But there is some differentiation.
Some people say hey our
cereal is more delicious
and it's sweeter while others say
our cereal is more nutritious
and they build a brand
and they do marketing, etc, etc.
And because there is some differentiation,
there's a little bit more ability
for the individual players
unlike in perfect competition
there's a little bit
more ability for them
to dictate their price.
They might say, hey
we're a premium product,
people think we're healthier so we might
be able to charge a little bit more.
You can almost imagine that
they have their own unique
demand curve because of
that differentiation.
You can imagine the market in
something like, well shirts.
That's another example.
Where a lot of folks can produce shirts,
but some people might be able
to differentiate themselves.
They're more stylish,
there's better quality,
they advertise, they build a brand.
And so once again, that would
be monopolistic competition.
So anyway, the big picture here
is really just for you to get
familiar with these words.
What do they mean?
And then what context or
what will they imply about
the differentiation or
the number of firms?
And actually before I leave,
I'll throw out one other word
that you'll hear a little bit less
than what I just talked
about and it sounds
like monopoly but it is monopsony.
And I'm gonna do this
in a unique color here.
Let me see, I haven't done
anything in this salmon yet.
Monopsony.
Which you won't hear
it as much as monopoly.
And it's really the opposite situation.
Instead of one supplier and many buyers,
a monopsony is one big
buyer and many suppliers.
So for example, if you
have one big box store
in a small town, and so they're
the only employer in that town
they might have monopsony
in the labor market,
where they're the only people who can hire
and there's a lot of people
who are looking for jobs.
But we can talk more about
that in other videos.